دا معك مؤمن من رفح والتي جعلها الناز
النازحون الان ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه كيف
هي اخر التطورات
فيها وضع انساني كارثي وصعب جدا وللغاية
هي سواء الدوليه او المحليه الفلسطينيه
على تقديم المساعدات والمعونات لهؤلاء
النازح النازحين من ملبس وماكل ومشرب
وايضا من امدادات طبيه في مدينه خان يونس
التي تظهر امامنا على الشاشه تتواصل
الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه على مختلف
المناطق نشاهد الان غاره اسرائيليه
جديده من طبيعه اعمده الدخان يبدو انها
تستهدف مربعا سكنيا جديدا اليوم كان حافلا
في الغارات الاسرائيليه الكثيفه على مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خانيونس تحديدا في منطقه
البلد وايضا في المناطق الغربيه والجنوبيه
منها في بطن السمين وبير عيه بالاضافه الى
المناطق الشرقيه سلسله من الغارات الجويه
تشنها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مختلف
المناطق في مدينه خان يونس من شرقها الى
غربها ومن شمالها الى جنوبها كما رصدناه
خلال الساعات الماضيه من هذه المنطقه
المشرفه على مدينه خانيونس في مدينه
خانيونس حتى هذه اللحظه وصل الى
المستشفيات 19 شهيدا منذ ساعات صباح هذا
اليوم من بين الشهداء اثنين من الشبان
حاولوا انتشال جثمان امراه امام مستشفى
الامل التابع للهلال الاحمر وهي استشهدت
نتيجه قنصها برصاص جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اثناء محاولتهم انتشال جثمان
هذه الشهيده اي استهدفتهم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وقناص جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
باطلاق النار المباشر عليهم ما ادى الى
ارتقائه ما شهيدان وبالتالي الحصيله ترتفع
الى 19 شهيدا منذ ساعات الصباح الى جانب
استمرار القصف المدفعي على مختلف المناطق
تحديدا في منطقه جوره العقاد الى الغرب من
مدينه خانيونس والتي تتصاعد منها اعمده
دخان ايضا تتواصل اشتباكات عنيفه وضاره
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كتائب القسام قالت انها
استهدفت تجمعا لجنود جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بجوار اليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
بقذيفه الياسين المضاده للدروع الى جانب
ايضا الاوضاع الانسانيه الصعبه للغايه
داخل مدينه خان يونس نتيجه استمرار
الغارات وعدم تمكن الطواقم الطبيه وسيارات
الاسعاف من التحرك خارج مستشفى الامل و
خارج مجمع ناصر الطبي او حتى سيارات
الاسعاف والنقاط الطبيه التي تتواجد في
منطقه المواصي غربيه المدينه لا يمكن
يمكنها الدخول الى المدينه الحديث عن عديد
الشهداء بالاضافه الى وجود الالاف داخل
هذه المدينه محاصرين سواء داخل مراكز
الايواء في مدارس تابعه للاناره او في
مستشفى الامل او حتى مجمع ناصر الطبي اطر
الناس وسكان مدينه خان يونس الى دفن ذويهم
الشهداء داخل اسوار مجمع ناصر الطبي بسبب
الحصار الذي يضربه اليات ودبابات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مقبره المدينه
الى جانب ايضا هناك مناشدات من قبل اداره
مجمع ناصر
الطب